[Música]
Andrés Manuel López Obrador presidente
de México instó a su homólogo Joe biden
a poner fin al abandono y desprecio de
Estados Unidos hacia América Latina y el
Caribe en la reunión que mantuvieron
esto como paso previo a la reunión
trilateral junto al Primer Ministro
canadiense Justin trudeo ampliamos desde
la capital Mexicana donde tuvo lugar el
encuentro
[Música]
más de una docena de fallecidos dejan
los enfrentamientos con la policía en la
ciudad peruana de juliaca en el sur del
país allí en las regiones fronterizas
con Bolivia se reactivaron especialmente
las protestas desde el inicio de año
contra el gobierno de Dina boluarte y
por nuevas elecciones
en Brasil miles de personas marcharon
por las calles de las principales
ciudades del país para condenar el
ataque contra la democracia seguidores
de la expresidente Jair bolsonaro
asaltaron el domingo las sedes de los
tres poderes del estado en Brasilia
nuestro equipo en Río de Janeiro estuvo
en una de las manifestaciones
Bienvenidos a una nueva informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
México en donde este lunes se reunieron
los presidentes precisamente de México y
de Estados Unidos Andrés Manuel López
Obrador instó a Joe biden a que Estados
Unidos frenará una actitud de abandono y
de desprecio hacia América Latina y el
Caribe Ryder respondió que la
responsabilidad de su país No es solo
con el hemisferio occidental escuchamos
los alegatos de ambos mandatarios
que es el momento de terminar
con ese olvido ese abandono ese desdén
hacia América Latina y el Caribe
comenzar con usted una etapa nueva
entre los pueblos y Naciones del
continente a partir del respeto y de la
ayuda mutua
presidente biden usted tiene la llave
para abrir y mejorar sustancialmente las
relaciones entre todos los países del
continente americano
México es un verdadero socio y cuando
trabajamos juntos con valores comunes y
respeto mutuo nada queda fuera de
nuestro alcance por eso discutimos Cómo
podemos profundizar aún más esa relación
no solo como en México sino también con
el hemisferio occidental
Eso incluye fortalecer nuestras cadenas
de suministro para hacer que el
hemisferio sea aún más competitivo y
también discutimos nuestra seguridad
compartida incluida nuestra acción
conjunta para probar la Plaga de
fentanilo que ha matado a 100.000
estadounidenses hasta ahora y Cómo
podemos hacer frente a la migración
irregular
algo en lo que creo vamos por buen
camino sobre todo ambos nos
comprometemos a buscar un futuro mejor
basado en la paz y la prosperidad para
todos nuestros pueblos nuestra
correspondencia de México Mario
carbonell Nos daba previamente más
detalles de lo acontecido este lunes
entre ambos mandatarios y del inicio de
la trilateral
dio inicio ya en la Ciudad de México la
Cumbre de líderes de América del Norte
con una cena ofrecida en Palacio
Nacional por parte del anfitrión el
mandatario anfitrión Andrés Manuel López
Obrador ASUS homólogos de Estados Unidos
y Canadá Joe biden y Justin trude previo
a esta cena de los tres dirigentes tuvo
lugar la reunión bilateral México
Estados Unidos en la que López Obrador
le plantó a baile la necesidad de poner
en marcha una nueva política de
integración económica y social que no
nada más se ocupe del comercio sino que
también vaya acompañada de una inversión
Fuerte una inversión pública y Privada
para mejorar las condiciones de vida de
los pueblos de todo el continente sin
excepción alguna en ese sentido el
presidente biden dijo que los Estados
Unidos es el país que más aporta para
ayuda al desarrollo no solo en el
hemisferio sino también en otras
regiones del mundo y por ello no es
posible concentrar únicamente los
esfuerzos en el continente americano no
obstante se dijo confiado en lograr que
esta aprovechar esta coyuntura
inigualable para mejorar las relaciones
entre los países del continente dijo que
es muy importante tener esta ocasión de
discutir la seguridad compartida entre
México y Estados Unidos y también
abordar el tema de la migración
irregular durante el día los las esposas
de los presidentes tanto J baden como
Beatriz Gutiérrez Müller tuvieron un
encuentro para promover la lectura
también la esposa de biden tuvo
actividades privadas para el
empoderamiento de las mujeres y ya por
la tarde emitieron un mensaje un
pronunciamiento conjunto en el que
destacaron la importancia de promover
los valores como la familia la educación
y fortalecer la democracia la Cumbre de
líderes de América del Norte tendrá su
reunión formal Este martes ya con los
tres líderes por la tarde y al concluir
se espera un mensaje a medios
Vamos hasta el Sur de Perú el número de
muertos por enfrentamientos con las
fuerzas de seguridad en la ciudad de
juliaca asciende a más de una docena
esto luego que el año 2023 comenzara con
nuevas manifestaciones y bloqueos
especialmente en las regiones
fronterizas con Bolivia en contra del
gobierno de Dina boluarte y por nuevas
elecciones desde el inicio de las
protestas luego del encarcelamiento de
Pedro Castillo son ya 43 los fallecidos
en todo el país
de un hombre del efectivo policial que
te pone de rodillas apuntando
[Música]
unos cuatro pasos de esos cuatro pasos
al gobierno central de que cómo es
posible que podamos tener tantos
fallecidos
en Brasil sigue la conmoción y la
condena ante el asalto de ayer a las
sedes de los tres poderes del estado en
la capital Brasilia este lunes miles de
personas se reunieron y recorrieron
varias calles de las principales
ciudades del país en apoyo al gobierno
de Lula da Silva y en contra de lo que
muchos denuncian como un intento de
golpe de estado de los bolsonaristas en
Río de Janeiro Valeria sacona y
amiguidara participaron en la
movilización y nos enviaron al siguiente
reporte
[Aplausos]
la intensa lluvia cientos de cariocas
han salido hoy a la plaza de zinelandia
para mostrar su repulsa contra los actos
antidemocráticos que ayer sacudieron la
ciudad de Brasilia y todo el país no es
la única ciudad donde Defensores de la
Democracia quieren hacer sentir su voz
en las principales capitales de este
país tan grande Hay personas diciendo No
a la violencia
estamos aquí para demostrar que no
estamos de acuerdo con Los atentados
estamos a favor de la democracia y que
deseamos que no haya amnistía que todos
los acusados sean presos y juzgados como
se debe
la democracia en Brasil es un proceso
muy reciente
[Música]
nos impidieron debutar durante más de 21
años
Hoy no podemos permitir que controlen
nuestro voto nuestro poder de elegir
tenemos que Mostrar que el otro lado
existe que dice no no queremos eso
queremos respeto a los resultados
electorales queremos la garantía de las
libertades democráticas y vamos a
combatir la extrema derecha
Además hoy a lo largo de todo el día han
sido desmantelados varios campamentos de
bolsonaristas en muchas ciudades de
Brasil en Brasilia ha habido al menos
1.200 detenidos y aquí en Río de Janeiro
también se ha procedido a desmantelarlo
ha habido resistencia Y algún periodista
herido en Venezuela el fiscal general
del país emitió órdenes de arresto
contra los tres nuevos líderes de la
opositora asamblea nacional por delitos
que incluyen la traición nuestra
corresponsal Daniela Zambrano nos
ampliaba
para poner en contexto a los
televidentes se trata de la asamblea
nacional que fue electa en el año 2015
que ha venido prolongando su pedido tras
el desconocimiento de las elecciones
legislativas del año 2020 en las que la
oposición venezolana no participó por
considerar que no estaban dadas las
condiciones el propio fiscal general fue
quien confirmó las órdenes de capturas
contra Dinora figuera marianela
Fernández y auristela Vázquez Quienes
fueron acusadas de usurpación de
funciones traición a la patria y
legitimación de capitales también se
emitió una alerta Roja de Interpol
contra estas ciudadanas pues no se
encuentran en Venezuela dos de ellas
están en España y otra está en Estados
Unidos El fiscal general durante la
rueda de prensa insistió en la
corrupción bajo el denominado gobierno
interino que presidía Juan guaidó y una
vez más preguntó dónde estaban todos los
recursos que ha manejado entre los años
2019 y 2023 paralelamente se conoció que
este lunes el departamento del tesoro de
Estados Unidos emitió una licencia que
permite a esta asamblea nacional
opositora controlar los activos en el
exterior como lo es si con la filial de
pedevesa en Estados Unidos y en esta
licencia se especifica que no está
permitido el control de estos activos
por parte del parlamento que preside
Jorge Rodríguez esto luego de que se
eliminara la figura del gobierno
interino que presidía Juan guaidó y se
crearan estas comisiones de la asamblea
nacional para poder continuar controlar
los activos en el exterior que no pueden
ser manejados por la administración de
Nicolás maduro tras las sanciones
impuestas a su gobierno hasta aquí las
noticias sigan conectados
[Música]